joining me now Horace Cooper project 21
chairman Horace
so now racism and sexism are the reasons
you cannot really criticize Kamala
Harris who has an incredible Talent of
taking up paragraphed after paragraph
saying nothing
oh it's worse than saying nothing it's
what did that woman just say I mean it's
remarkable that this President is
setting back the uh quality and talent
perspective that Americans have on
blacks and on women he has managed to
pick some of the worst choices in very
very critical positions this woman
needs help but the help should start
with let's tackle a responsibility that
she can handle competently it's not the
vice presidency it wasn't even as a
senator you may recall she was one of
the first people to drop out of the
presidential race remember what the New
York Times said about that camp campaign
it's I'm I'm summing it up here but
basically it was one of the worst run
campaigns absolutely was if it managed
to offend everybody to get to know her
was to dislike her well that's not
really a winning strategy but they're
stuck right Horace they're stuck with
they can't get rid of her but will they
even be able to they may not be able to
but what they shouldn't do is this
shameful thing of saying if you and I
see what is obvious for everyone to see
that this is the most incompetent vice
president that this country has ever had
if we say that that somehow anti-woman
or anti-black this incompetent president
has selected so many Talent as people
it's remarkable no Jennifer grantolm I
mean
[Music]
yeah you can't even I mean you know at
some point you do arrive at a loss of
words there is no nothing to say but
CNN's van Jones obviously got that call
from Anita Dunn watch this
she is in such an unusual position she's
a woman she's black she's Asian and
she's running alongside the oldest
person to ever do it so she's
essentially running for president that's
what she's doing and I think people
understand that but I think she
understands that and I think I think
that she's going to rise to the occasion
so okay she's had three years to rise to
the occasion that isn't going to happen
but by the way this is way off message
way off message elect Joe Biden and when
he stumbles and falls down here's who
you're going to get the American people
have already decided this President is
heading into a re-election with some of
the lowest approval numbers we have seen
but guess whose numbers are worse
Kamala Harris's so for him to say vote
for him and you're going to get her
that's not on message I don't think that
that doesn't help them that she's
running for president Horace so good to
see you in the studio all right thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else